still little is known about the eight
victims
killed in the atlanta asian spa
shootings only that
six were asian women police would not
say wednesday whether they had worked at
the spas
but did say that the suspect 21-year-old
robert aaron long
had targeted the businesses he does
claim that it was not racially motivated
he apparently has an issue what he
considers a
sex fiction and sees these locations as
something that allows him to to
to go to these places and it's a
temptation for him that he wanted to
eliminate
police say long has confessed to the
shootings and is scheduled to appear in
court on thursday
atlanta's mayor says there is no
evidence the spas were covered for sex
work
we certainly will not begin to blame
victims
and as far as we know in atlanta these
are legally
operating businesses experts say
the stereotype of asian spots doubling
as brothels
is another facet of the anti-asian
racism
growing in the united states the group
stop
aapi hate formed in response to the rise
in xenophobia since kovid
has collected nearly 3 800 reports of
hate incidents toward asian americans
in the past year i think there's a lot
of fear and trepidation right now
and you know you've seen it over the
past few months to
for us seeing our elders being attacked
certainly folks are scared some
communities have formed
citizen patrols in response to the
uptick in random violence against asians
and they've expressed
anger at law enforcement's refusal in
some cases
to call the attacks hate crimes police
in atlanta
say they've yet to decide whether to use
the label for this week's killings
we've received a number of calls about
is this a hate crime
we are still early in this investigation
whatever the motivation here i know that
asian americans are
and very very concerned
because as you know i've been speaking
about the brutality against asian
americans
for the last couple months and i think
it
is very very troubling
president biden says the fbi and the
department of justice are involved in
the investigation
heidi joe castro al jazeera washington